なので あの  二十八種類ですね
その 二十八種類あるというんだけど
あの この前説明した四つだけ
やっぱり具体的な あの
物質なんですね  その四つについてもいろいろきめ細かく考えると
いろいろ本当に四つあるんですか？ないかとか考えるかもしれませんだけど
で 考えるならば結局いろんな問題が出てきますしね
ただ 本当に物質はあるんですから
例えばこの四つはお互いに四つでなければ存在しないし
そうすると本当に自立して存在するものではなくなっちゃう
それだったら結局ないものではないかとかね
まあそういうのはまあいくらでも考えられるんですね
ですから この特にあの
中観という大乗の世界で
この中論などを作ったこの宗派では
この何も存在しないんだと
全部空だと 何もないんだというふうに
まあそこまで考えているんです
そういうのはもう考えればそうなるだけであって
ですから どこまでも考え方を持っていったとしても
結局まあ困って混乱して終わるだけなんですね
ですから 人間は考えれますから
いくらか考えたっても構いませんだけど
まあほどほどなところで考え方をやめた方がいいんですね
まあそういうことで この理解できる
まあほどほどなところで
この地水火風という四つのエネルギーの流れで
物質の世界は出来上がっているんだと
そういうふうに言ってるんですね
例えば水という引き 引き寄せるエネルギーと
火という回転させるエネルギーと
風という引き離すエネルギーだけでいったならば
なんとなく何をそうしているんですか？と聞きたくなっちゃうし
それだったら地という概念を入れて
地という現象もあるんだ
だから地水火風という四つの現象があるんだと
で まあそれだったらあるのは地だけではないかと思う人が
あの 考える可能性はあるんですね
まあそういうのはまあ勝手な
まあ勝手ではなくて まあ考えればどこまででも考えれますから
まあそこら辺で説明はちょっと難しいところと
なんか説明はだぶったりしたり
それからちょっと矛盾のように見えたりする可能性はあるんですが
どうせ考えることですから
じゃあそれからこの まあ存在の基本的な
まあ存在って物質的な存在の基本的なエネルギーの流れは四つあるんだと
その四つができたところで
物質の一番基本的な一番小さなユニットが生まれるんだと
いわゆる素粒子一個が生まれるためには
この地水火風がある割り当てで組み合わせなくちゃいけないんですね
で 地水火風が四つまとめたら
そこに物質的な存在があるというふうに言えるんです
その四つは決して分かれることはできないんですね
地と水と火と風は引き離せることはできない
一つも自分だけでは一人だけで存在するということはないんです
で そういうことで 世の中のすべての存在
宇宙の存在 体そのもの
何だかんでも まあ地水火風と四つしかないというふうなことにするんです
で 普通我々この科学の世界では
例えば原子があるんだと
原子の中に核があるんだと
その周りに電子があるんだとか言ってますけど
それは見ることも聞くことももう何もできないんですね
いわゆる直感で体験することはできないんですね
その代わりにいろいろ工夫して
やっぱり原子はあるんだということは
いろいろ工夫して計算して
あの見なくちゃいけない
まあ機械は発展しましたから
まあ現代はいくらか原子ぐらいのものは見えるようになってるんですね
でもその場合も 原子そのものを見えるわけじゃなくて
このいろんな科学的な法則を使って
ここに原子があるぞという推測を作って
その推測を計算して あのブラウン管で映像化するんですね
いわゆる数値データをブラウン管で映像になってしまっちゃう
ですから 我々はこのブラウン管で見られる映像を見て
あるいは写真版で写るその映像を見て
あ これは原子だと決めるだけで
それ我々目で見えるものはかなり巨大なもので
原子そのものっていうのはそんなにそんなものではないんですね
とにかく原子っていうのは目に見えるぐらいのものではない
で そこで原子やら素粒子やらこの電子やら
そういう話になると 我々には直感的に体験できない
ですから 使う機械によって使う計算式によって
それなりの意見は変わってしまっちゃうんですね
昔はそれほど顕微鏡を発展してなかったんだから
ただの仮定で推測だけであって
今は電子顕微鏡を発展しているんだだから他のもっと違う風な原子のことを考えたりとかしているし
それから計算公式やら実験公式が変わったんだから
さらに素粒子の存在まで言ってしまっちゃってとか
そういうふうになっているんですね
それでも何一つも仏教から言えば
あなたは知ってるんですかと聞いたら
本当はその人は知らないんです
そんなものは ただ 計算結果はそうなりましたと
実験結果はそうなりましたから
これはこういうことであるだろうというふうなことになります
推測だから嘘と言っているわけじゃないんです
だから推測の中でも結構真理に近い推測はできるんですね
例えば我々は人が目から涙流していると
鼻からもう鼻水が出ているんだと
顔色ちょっと悪いんだと感じたら
あなた悩んでるんではないかと推測はできるんですね
それは大体当たりますよ
それで でもそれは推測なんですね
そこでその人に聞いたら
聞いてみたら あんた本当に悩んでますか？と
いえ ちょっときつい薬を鼻に入れたところで
まあすごい涙が出て もう鼻水が出て
ちょっときついんですよと言った答えが返ってきたら
我々の推測は間違っているようになってしまっちゃうんです
ですから 人が泣くんだから確実に悩んでるんですよということにはならないし
推測っていうのはそういうふうなもので
当たるかもしれません
当たらないかもしれませんし
ですから そこら辺も仏教では
仏教論理学では気をつけるんですね
人間には何でも経験できないんですね
いろんなものはやっぱり推測で考えなくちゃいけないんですね
だからって何でも推測でうまくいくということはないんですね
仏教の認識っていうのは
種類に分けてプラティクシャアヌマーナというんですけど
で プラティクシャアヌマーナってそれはサンスクリット語の言葉で
これ特に上座仏教だけの
理論ではないんです 一応
仏教の時代で発展したプラティクシャっていうのは
自分で直感的に体験する知識
知恵です 知識 知恵ですね
直感的に知ってるもの
アヌマーナというのは
いろんな情報から推測するもの
ですから 仏教でいうのはアヌマーナという仮定
推測するためにはプラティクシャがなければいけませんと
いわゆるこれは体験であって
プラティクシャは体験であって
これは推測であると それ二つしか人間には認知認識方法はありませんと
人間持っている認識はこの二種類に分けられるんですね
その中で確実なのはこの直感であって
体験であるプラティクシャなんですね
これは 確実性はない これは百パーセント正しいとは言えないんです
ですから 仏教の論理学はこのアヌマーナの論理学なんですね
人間はどのようにアヌマーナをすればいいんですか？どんなアヌマーナは正しいんですか？どんなアヌマーナは正しくないんですかと
それはいちいち説明する
言葉のどうやって言葉を使った方がいいんですかと
どうやって論理をつけた方がいいんですかと
例えばカラスは白いですよと
という人には結論を出せることができるんだそうですね
で それにアヌマーナで
どういうものならば 例えば出来上がっているもの
出来上がっているものは白であるならば
それは白いんですね 我々普通の論理もので
例えば白い紙で作った本は何色ですか？それ白いんですね
白い紙で作った本は黄色いではないんだから
そこで だからカラスも白いですよと
そこでパッキャクシャを使うんです
パッキャクシャは 例えば白い紙で作った本は
我々は白色であることを知っているんですね
紙は白いだから本は白いですと
その結論から紙は白いだから本は白いですと
ですから カラスは骨で出来ているんですね
大体 カラスの骨は残念ながら白いですね
ですからカラスは白いですと結論付けちゃうんだと
そうすると でも我々知っているカラスは白くはないし
黒いし そういうのはヘレクッサと言うんですね
ですから そういう風にも
ただ好き勝手にいろいろ結論付けて
その結論に基づいて次の次の推理をしながらしながら
そんな好き勝手に言ったっても
とんでもないことになってしまっちゃうんですから
そこら辺でどう あの 何でしたっけ
どう気をつけた方がいいかという
この仏教の論理学と言語に対するアプローチとか
またいろいろテキストやら学問的な分野ができているんです
かなり膨大な量の それにしたっても読みたければ
この Buddhist Logic というテキスト １
と２があります このシャガツキというソーレン人が日本
ソーレン訳して それはもうそれから英訳していて
かなり有名な権威を持ってるテキストなんです
それはあるサンスクリットの本をそのまま丸ごとに英訳したものなんですね
それがザーというのは大体論理学で論理ですからわかります
で ですから この 大体私たちが喋っている世界のほとんどアヌマーナの世界なんですね
私たちはほとんど我々知っている知識のまあ九十パーセント以上アヌマーナの推測の世界なんですね
人間がそれに全然気づいてないんです
偉そうに自分が知ってるんだ
こうだああだこうだとかと言うんです
私はかなりこのいろんな哲学やら宗教に攻撃しているのも
一つのこの基本的な考えはそれなんです
私はなんでそんなに失礼な
失礼なことやら発言やら言いますかって
別にそんな言う気持ちもないし
気持ちいいものでもないんだけど
人は偉そうに質問するんだけど
その本人が自分が知ってるよと言うんだけど
ただの推測ではないかということを本人気づいてないんですね
あなたの体験ですかと聞いたら
向こうは機嫌悪くなっちゃうんですね
私は知ってるんだと思う勘違いしているんだから
だから僕はその概念自体を馬鹿にするしか
僕にも何も方法残ってないんですね
もう紙のお話でもいいし
伝道瞑想の話でもいいし
そういう宗教としていろんなこと言ってるかもしれません
僕はいきなりそれをもう完全に馬鹿にするしか
僕にとっては方法ないんですね
なぜそうやってますかと
その教える側も単なるアヌマーナに基づいて喋っていて
何かの体験があって その体験に基づいてありとあらゆる解釈をして
その解釈をシステム化
組織化して それに強引な人間の理論を入れちゃって喋ると
なんとなく科学のように
論理ごとく真実ごとく見えてしまっちゃうんですね
ですから この何々もどきみたいなものであって
それにもサンスクリット語でももどきという言葉があります
これアーヴァーサと読むんですね
アーヴァーサ アーヴァーサっていうのはいろいろ意味がありますけど
論理学ではアーヴァーサという言葉を使うのは
本当のように見える でも本当でないもの
ですからカラスは白いですよときちんと論理付けると
なんか否定できない論理構想なんですね
白いもので出来上がったら白いではないかと
それでいくらでも証拠を出せるんですね
例えば人間の体の中でも赤いやら黒いやら黄色
いろんなものあるんだけど
皮膚は白いんだったらその人は白いんだというでしょうし
皮膚だけ黒いんだから黒人には黒人というでしょうに
体の中を見れば黒人白人何の色の差がないんですね
でも我々の事実としては
この人は黒いと この人は白いと
白人と黒人という二種類が出てきちゃうんですね
じゃあその差別するためにどれぐらいの差がありますか？ほんのかすかな皮膚の色だけなの
ですから 皮膚ぐらいのもう一パーセントもならない色を見て
体の全体の色を見て 一パーセントにもならない色で人を区別するんだから
もっとたくさんあるカラスの方がなんで白いと言わないんですかと
いくらでも論理できるんです
カラスの骨見たらもう体の結構量が面積取ってるんですね
体重から見たって骨の方が多いんだから
だからカラスの白いと言えるんです
だから論理構造はなかなかどうにもならない
もうきちんと出来上がっちゃうんですね
でもあれは 理論ではないんだと
あれはアーヴァーサなんですね
そういうことはありますから
この仏教を勉強する場合は
そこら辺 まあすごく気をつけているんですね
ただ みんなの気持ちよくなるように喋るということではなくて
このプラティクシャとアヌマーナ
それはよく理解して どこまでプラティクシャか
どこまでアヌマーナか
どこまで体験か どこまで推測かと
その推測はやっぱり可能な推測か
あるいは無理な推測かと
ちゃんと知っておかなくちゃいけない
それは瞑想実践の世界でも使うんです
瞑想はこのプラクティシャの世界で体験の世界なんですね
だから体験には金物アヌマーナなんですね
アヌマーナ使うといろんなへんてこりな宗教が生まれてくるんです
そのアヌマーナも正しいアヌマーナではないんです
いわゆる正しい推測じゃないんです
ある人が瞑想すると もうなんとなく光のようなものを感じたんだと
それでその人は自分こそ世界の唯一の解脱者だともう言いふらしちゃったんですね
そこはまあ本人がいろいろ薬でも飲んだかもしれませんし
何かのわけで光なんか何かを体験したというならば
それがプラクティシャであるんですね
その人の経験ですから
それで だから自分が唯一の解脱者だというのは何ですかと
そこでプラクティシャとアヌマーナ
人間自分が知識持ってるのに
知識持ってるこの人間が知識のことを知らない
そこで大勢の人 ああそうですか
じゃあその人にもうとことんもう身を投げて
身も心も投げて もう折伏というんですか
もう従いましょうと言って
自分がいろんなひどい目に遭ってしまっちゃうんですね
だから結局どっちでも悪いんですね
で 初めて我々も知識持ってるなら考えなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば どこかに証拠があるならば
光見える人は唯一の解脱者であると
そういう証拠 そういうプラクティシャがどこかにあるならば
その人にそういう推測できるんですね
私は光を体験しました
そこで唯一の解脱者も
その解脱者になったというためには光を体験したんだ
だから光を体験することを
すなわち唯一の解脱者になることだと
であるならば 私も唯一の解脱者であるというふうに順番で結論つけなくちゃいけないんですね
論理を そういう論理は全く使ってないんですね
だから 完全たるもう子供さえ使わない無茶苦茶な概念のからくりだけなんですね
そこへみんなやられちゃうんですね
だから どんな人の考え方にもやられなくて
しっかりと知恵を守るためには
そういう何が知識か 何が推測かと
何が知恵かと 何が達者か
何がアヌマーナかと はっきりと理解しておかないといけないんですね
そういう心の育ち方は
まあ一応仏教ではまあやってるんですね
とにかく人を束縛するためではなくて
人を自由にするための教えというのは
そういう深いわけがあるんです
そういう論理の話をいくらか置いておいて
今日は論理の話じゃないんだから
この四大元素の話に戻ります
じゃあなんでアビダンマで四大元素
地水火風の四大元素ありますかと
その後 それは科学的に言えばきちんと科学的な実験証拠があるんだから
仏教の四大元素よりは科学の世界で言っている元素論の方が正しいのではないかとか
我々は思うかもしれません
例えばカーボンやら酸素やら窒素やらヘリウムやら
いろいろプルトニウム
プラチナムいろいろあるんじゃないかと
そこで核の話やら もう
エレクトロンでエレクトロンやらトウトロンやらニュートロンやらいろいろもう話が出ていて
それにそれなりのわけがあって
科学者が喋ってるんだから
いい加減に喋ってるわけじゃないんだから
それぐらいの計算とか何にもないんですね
仏教では 何も道具も使ってないんですね
だから仏教の方はもうまあもうたまたまいい加減に言ってることではないかとも
我々には考えられるんですね
で 仏教の世界の違うところは
この道具を使わないことなんですね
道具を使って見るものは全てはアヌマーナなんです
残念ですけど 何か道具を使って我々は何か知恵を得ると
それは直感体験ではなくて推測なんですね
じゃあこの壁は左側右側までどれぐらい長いんですかと
幅がどれぐらいあるんですか？と言ったら
すぐどうします？あの測る道具を持ってきて
テープを持ってきて ああ
やっぱり これ５メートルありますよとか
6メートルと 20 センチですよと言っちゃうでしょう
ということは それは体験ですか？全くない
テープを持っていろいろこれでここまで
ここは 1メートル ここからここまで 2メートルとか
何とか何とか考えて 自分の頭で推測するものであって
ですから たとえ壁の長さ高さにしたっても
それは直感じゃないんです
残念ですけど そんなものは全部推測なんです
なぜかというと 道具使ってそれを知ってるんだから
じゃあ計算は何ですか？それも道具なんです
計算結果でこうなりました
例えば物理学はほとんど計算まず計算あって
それから出てくるんですから
推測の世界なんです 推測は完全に間違ってるよと言ってるわけじゃないんです
推測の中ではまあ結構その通りのものはいっぱいありますから
それは我々は推測の世界に生きている
それで仏教はこの達者のことを大事にする
直感というのは この日本で言ってる直感ではない
それを誤解してほしくない
何もわけもわからない
いきなり頭に浮かんだ考え方に直感と言うんですね
何も理由も何もない そんなものに直感と言えない
直感でない直接知るという意味なんです
で 例えばね 今日はあの友達が来るで今日はなんとか自分友達の何々さんが今日は来るでしょうと
なんでそういう？いえ
私の直感でなんか来るような感じがしますよと
それは決して仏教でいう直感じゃないんです
仏教でいう直感が 例えば何々さんという友達が来てピンポンを鳴らしたところでも直感じゃないんです
それでもう部屋に入ってみて
その人を見たら それは何々さんですね
それが直感なんです それは達者な経験だから
直感というのはどんな理由をつけてもこの変わらない真実なんです
例えば自分の部屋を訪ねて
自分の友達の田中さんが来ましたと
そこでピンポンの音でそれあれ田中やと決めたら
それは推測であって そこでドアを開けてみたら
もう田中さんでしたと
そのあ 田中さんではないかと
その知恵が知識が直感なんです
そこで他の人は何言おうが
それは関係ないんです
日本の総理大臣が出て
これは田中さんではなくて他の人ですと言ったっても
それはもう通用しない
それは直感ですね ですから
直感という言葉ではすごいちょっと意味の差があるということは覚えておいてください
直接道具使わずに知ること
ピンポンで決める場合は道具を通って知ってるんですね
ピンポンでは耳に音が入る
その音を媒介して道具として
その音は人が鳴らさなきゃピンポンは音しないし
それは過去のことで知っている
今の時間にピンポン鳴らすならば
新聞屋さんでもなく 郵便局でもなく
田中さんではないかと
という推測なんですね
ですから 日本でごく普通に言ってる直感というのは
推測にも当たらない ただの勘なんですね
ただの思いなんですね
まぁとにかくそういうふうに
皆様が今まで知ってる知識の世界はもう繰り返すちゃうことをいっぱい言わなくちゃいけないんです
それはもう覚悟しておかないと
今まで大事にありがたく思っていたいろんな知識やらいろんなものをすぐ覆しちゃうというか
繰り返してしまっちゃうんですね
で わかりやすく言えば
我々の知識というのはほとんど推測ですから
ほとんど そういうことで
この小さい花粉の場合に場合に限って
それ直感でわかるんですね
いわゆる認識できるんですね
ですから  4つにしているんです
顕微鏡はいりません そこで知るということは
我々は知るということは
体をもって知ってるんですね
体でもこのいろんな場所が決まってあって
この場所でこの情報を知る
この場所でこの情報を知るというふうにあるんですね
テレビだったら このあの
英語だったらチューブというんですが
日本でブラウン管ですね
ブラウン管で目に入るものは見える
でも耳に入るものはスピーカーで聞かなくちゃいけないんです
でも スピーカーから出て出る情報を目でいくら見たっても全く知りません
そこでブラウン管をいくら耳を当ててみたっても
何も音は出ません 何も認識は生まれません
ブラウン管の方に目を置く
スピーカーの方に耳を置く
そこでテレビの重さとか知りたければ
いくら見ていたっても何キロかわからないんですね
いくらテレビの音を聞いたっても
あれは 二十三キロですね
あのテレビは でわからないんです
その場合はやっぱり体で知るしか方法ないんですね
どれぐらい重いかっていうこと
これ 二十三か二十ということは推測なんです
それは道具使うでしょ
だからあれは確証ではないんです
道具使わずにテレビを持ってみると
我々は何か知ってるんです
その時も 数値では言えませんだけど
あ これはまあ持てるぐらい軽いとかね
これはこれ持てますよと
あ これはもうやっと持てるぐらいですよと
このテレビはまあ二人ぐらいなければ持ちませんよという風に人間を体験で知ってるんですね
そこには残念ながら数学はないんです
推測使ったら この人にはまあ二十キロまでのものは持つことはできるんだと
その場合は測りやらいろんなものを使って
自分にはせいぜいギリギリまで持てるものは持ってみてください
それで持ったところで
それを測りに入れて測ってみて
ああ やっぱり二十キロだと決めるんですから
そこはそういうふうに考えておいてください
ですから そこでこの地水火風の場合は
この本当はアビダンマでは地水火風に対する認識論は語らないんですが
これはちょっと進んだところの勉強になっちゃいますけど
基本的なところでは言わないんです
で えーと 地水火風は何とか体で知ることはできるんです
例えば地球の僕は質量とか重さとか
そういう言葉を使ったんですね
それは説明に使った言葉で
とにかく我々体で知るのは地と火なんですね
パタウィとテージを体で知ってるんです
何か捕まったら体に触れるんですね
体に触れるでしょ その体に触れるエネルギーは地なんです
そこに我々人間の言葉を使って
重いやとか軽いとか いろんな人間言葉使う
だからその言葉と事実はまたちょっといろいろ違うんではないかなと
例えば私は まあこのジュースの缶を取っても
眼鏡のケースを取っても
本を取っても 手で触ってるんですね
手で触って何かのエネルギーを感じる
ですから 手で触れるエネルギーはもう決まってるんです
ある一種類しかない それは地のエネルギーなんです
地というパタウィというエネルギーなんですね
それは何を触っても同じ
同じ情報を取っている
その情報の量があるんだから
硬い鉄の塊という言葉でいうものを手で持ってみたら
たくさん情報体に入る
そうすると重いという
紙一枚ぐらい手で持っていたら
量少ない情報を体に入る
それでこれは軽いという
いわゆるパタウィの言葉で言うならば
もう石の鉄の塊を持って取ってみたところで
パタウィがたくさん体に入ってしまっちゃう
紙を持ってみたところで
少量のパタウィのエネルギーが体に体で認識します
その多量と少量について頭で推測する
頭で推測して この鉄の塊は重いんだと
この紙は軽いんだと言うんです
だから重い軽いの推測であって
直感ではないんです でもそこに直感もありますよ
だから多量のパタウィが感じた
それは直感なんです 少量のパタウィが感じた
でも多量のパタウィに重いというものを重いと決めることは推測であって
少量のパタウィに軽いと決めることは推測なんですね
なぜ推測かというと この重い軽い概念はすっごくいい加減変化するんです
人間の心の中で その人に聞けば
じゃあ重いと軽いとあなた言うんだから
標準はどれぐらいですかと聞けばありますと頭の中で
何か標準があって重い軽いなりだすでしょ
じゃあ標準の重さは？そんなものないでしょ
標準の重さもないんだから
重い軽いというのはあまりにもいい加減なんですね
でも我々にはもう重い軽いという言葉なしに生きていられない
それをこそ真実の世界だと思っているんですね
標準はない そこで これは重いという人も
他の場所で他の時空関係で軽いと言うんですね
例えばカバンを持ってどこかへ出かけると
そこでいろいろ物を詰まったところでこれで大丈夫？と聞いたら
ああ 大丈夫 大丈夫 軽い
軽いと平気だって言ってるでしょ
言って 一キロぐらい やっぱりこれ重くて重くてって言うんじゃないですか
だからこのいい加減に次から次へと変わるんだから
この推測の世界 当てにならないんですね
軽いというのは事実で直感であったならば
朝は軽かったカバンはもう一時間経ったところで重くなるはずがないんですね
でもそこにある事実は
その人は長い時間かけてパタウィのエネルギーを長い時間かけて感じたということなんですね
長い時間かけてパタウィ感じたんだから
すごいパタウィを感じているようになっちゃって
それで重くなるんです
そういうことで体で感じるのはパタウィ
そこで次に我々が体で感じるのは
テージョ いわゆるカ ティですね
それからこのアポとワヨですか
スウィとフーは それはもう体でわからないんです
それも気をつけておいて
体ではわからない 体でわからないんだ
じゃあ目でわかりますかと
目でもわからない 耳でもわからない
耳には音と決まっていて
目には光と情報 形は決まっていて
で それはイデ 心でわかるんですね
頭でわからなく理解しなくちゃいけないんです
アポと アポじゃなくてワヨと
どういうとアポとワヨですね
スイートツー それ推測なんです
例えば紙を一枚持ってきて
私は持ったところでパタリだけわかります
地のエネルギーはわかります
それで私はさらに地のエネルギーを入れたりして
それを引っ張ってみようとする
引っ張るとなかなかその紙が伸ばしてもらいませんね
伸びないんです いわゆる自分の形をきちんと守ろうとしているんですね
持っている形を そういうのはなんとなくわかるんですね
それなんとなくわかるのは心でわかるんですね
引っ張ってもその通りだと
形は変わりませんと それでお互いの形を守ってお互いに引き寄せているエネルギーがあるということは推測しなくちゃいけないんです
で 力強く引っ張ればまあ割れますけど
それはまた別の話です
そこでスポンジでもいいし
風船でもいいし 持ってきて
我々はまあ押さえてみようとする
押さえるということは
風船を押さえる 押すということは
体から地のエネルギーを上げることなんですね
そうすると風船がまた逆に地のエネルギーを出しちゃって
私たちの押さえることに攻撃してるんですね
そうすると地のエネルギーは逆に働いていることはわかるんですね
それはただの物理学ですけどね
風船をこう押すと 風船の方から逆にエネルギーを出してくれると
抵抗として それで我々はわかるのは
この中には中は引き離す風のエネルギーはあるんだということは意識
意思でわかるんですね
それには道具は要りませんね
その様子を理解するために
ですから この真実の世界というか
本当の知恵の世界から言えば
あの科学で言っている
この鉄やら色々まあカルシウム
リン ナトリウム カリウムいろいろありますけどね
まあそういうものあるというよりは
地水火風あるんだと言った方がものすごく真実の世界には近いんです
認識の世界には近い ですから
仏教の物理学は物理学ではなくて
認識できる世界なんですね
やはり物質の世界は 我々はいかに認識しますかという説明は仏教の物理学であって
物理学ではないんです
人間が あるいは生命がどのように物質の世界は認識していますかと
そこの理論は認識するものは私たちはあると知っています
認識しないものはあるかないかどうかも関係はありませんと
それは人間の問題ではありません
我々は全く認識しないものは
マールンキャプット今日は皆様勉強なさったと思いますけどね
マールンキャプット様聞きますけどね
あなたはかつて見たこともない
今も見ていない これからも見ようともならない
目に見える形について
煩悩やらいろんなものを起こりますかと
起こるはずないでしょう
起こりません ですから
そこは人間の世界では関係ないんです
生命には関係ないんです
どんな生命にしたって
自分には見ることもできない
見たこともない 見てもないし
これからも見ようということにもならないものについては
どんな生命でも困ったりする必要はないんです
そのものについては煩悩が生まれるということでもないんです
そこで仏教の世界で なんで神という絶対存在に対してすごく無関心かと
別に否定してもないし
肯定してもないんだけど
無関心なんですね 馬鹿にしてるんですね
人間には認識することも不可能であって
認識したというならばそれは神ではないし
いわゆる神っていうのは無辺で
永遠でしょ？永遠たるものは永遠でないものに認識できますか？不可能なんです
いわゆる十年で死ぬ人が百年ぐらい生きてる人の生命に対して何が語られますか？自分の寿命は十年ですから
この人はこういう何年何月何日で生まれたんだと
それからここで若くなって
ここで年取って この日は死にましたと
記録も何もできませんよ
自分がもう転じしまっちゃいますから
だから永遠たるものを永遠でない自分が知るということは不可能である
それから神という概念にはこの先知というんですね
我々は先知じゃないんですね
ですから 微かな知恵を持っている人は
無量の知恵を持っている人を知るとあり得ふ話じゃないんです
もし人が神を体験したというのは
それは神ではないんです
ただの生の人間体験したものだから
それを人間に体験できる範囲の小さなものなんです
ですから 仏教の世界ではもうあまり当てにしないんですね
神という絶対的な概念
個人化した人格化したこの概念は
あり得ない話 それはまあ
別に神は認識できないということは
神を信じている宗教でもちゃんと言っているし
それであるならば どうしても我々には認識不可能で
ものであるならば 人間の問題からそれを外してあげなきゃいけないんです
関係ないんです その上で
お釈迦様は簡単に あなたは見たこともない
今も見ていない これからも見られないものについて
貪りやら怒りやら嫉妬やら苦しみ悩み生まれますかと
生まれるわけないでしょうに
ですから 知ったこともない
今知っているわけでもない
これから知られることもない
ものについて 我々には何の関係もないと
そういう単純論理でもう使わないんですね
でも推測とヘリコプターばっかり使っている人は
それにしたっても何か絶対的な存在あるんだと
仏教も他の宗教も同じこと言ってるけど
まだこうで言うんだから
もう腹が立つ以外方法ないんですね
だから僕はすごい攻撃的に何か言ったら
それで問題は終わりと
この人腹が立ちますから
なかなか話にならない
向こう側は腹が立つかもしれませんだけどね
この人に丁寧に質問したんだけど
結局まあ攻撃してしまっちゃったんだから
まあ二度とは質問しませんよと終わりますから
僕はその方が便利でいいと思っているんですね
相手の機嫌を取って まあ丁寧に質問しようと思ったら
それはもう死ぬまで話したくてももう終わりがないんですね
まあそういういろいろあります
私の話し方の裏にあるこの考え方っていうのは
そこを解決する方法は
このアビダンマはあまり良くないんだけど
まあこういう仏教から見たこの現実の世界を自分で一旦考えてみれば
ああなるほどと 仏教の見方っていうのはそういう見方だと理解できるんですね
だからこの仏教では この一つも訳なく批判しているわけじゃないんです
大変それなりの訳があるんですね
いろいろ瞑想の世界やらサマーディ世界やら
まあ僕も結構否定的に喋りますけど
それはもういい加減仏教を選んだから喋っている
このただ単なる迷信に基づいて言っているわけじゃないんです
それなりの まあ説明すると時間取る
もう長い長い深い深いわけがあるんです
まあそういうことで 地水火風の中で地は体験できる
で 水と風 火も体で体験
体験できる スートーフは
あの 体の体験を通して
意で認識できる まあ物質の世界はまあそこに
そこで終わります それからもう
また二十四残りますね
二十八種類の物質の中で二十四残りますね
この二十四の物質にはウパーダエルーパと呼んで
ウパーダエルーパ で 日本語の適当な名前は
まあちょっと出て こっちは依止と書いてますけどね
書いてます テキストをお持ちになるならばそこにあると思います
英語のテキストでもな
まあ英語のテキストでもなかなか
まあいい言葉を使ってないんですけど
あの 英語の世界知ってる人には derived って
だからこの fundamental matters, derived matters と書けるんだよ
あの この小さい括弧には fundamental matters って言うんですね
基本的な物質 あれは basic でもいいんですね basic
ですから four basics と簡単に言うんですね
基本的な四つ その basics に
基本的なものに基づいて derived
次の二十四は derived matters と読むんですね
この derive derivation
というのは まあ大体 まあ英語の世界で
まあ何かから何か出来上がるということで
で もう dependent matters と言っちゃっても正しいんだけど
この dependent という言葉は他のところで使いますから
使ってないみたいですね
あまり英語だとか言って困る必要ない
ただ名前の問題だけですけどね
まあ日本語では依止識と言ってるんですね
この derived matters というのは二十四種類ありまして basics
は四つであります basics basic
の四つはもう終わりました
説明も全部 で 今日からはこの依止識
二十四の説明です これから
今日からじゃなくて  [笑い]意識も
意識はいろいろカテゴリに分けて説明します
まずこのチャック この五つあります
チャック ソータ ガーナ
ジッハ カーヤ この四つの名前はパサード
これからいろいろパーリテキストやいろんなことを勉強すると
いろんな言葉でパサード
パンチャパサーダといえばチャックソータガーナジッハカーヤになります
パサダーニと言っちゃったらそれだけのことでもチャックソータガーナジッハカーヤと意味しますし
パサードルーパーニと言っちゃったらまたチャックソータガーナジッハカーヤになります
ですから このパーリ語の単語はいろいろ変化するんだから
もうどんな変化したっても
もうチャックソータガーナジッハカーヤという五つであることは理解しておけばわかります
で 一番目はチャックっていうのは日本語だったら眼
耳 眼ですね 眼 そういう眼耳鼻舌身という
目と耳と鼻と舌と体というふうな
ごく普通に俗的に言う五つですね
まあいきなり難しいアビダンマの分析論は
なんでそんなに即レベルに落ちたんですかと
ちょっとなんか考える可能性もありますんだけど
それは仏教のすごくいいところなんです
で 言ってる内容はすごい難しいんだけど
すごい俗的な次元で見たっても同じことなんです
それは真実だからなんです
ですから これは偉い科学者にも勉強すればものすごく大変なことだとわかるはずなんです
でも ごく普通の人がまあ見たって
まあ体 我々はまあ耳やら目やら鼻やらこれから物事を知ってるよと
それぐらい理解できる
結構っていうことなんですね
だから知識的にそんなに鋭さを要求してないんです
知識っていうのはアヌマンの世界だからね
どうせゴミだからね そんな別に要求してないんです
知識ある人はゴミ遊びをいっぱいやるだけのことなんですね
知識がそれほどない人は
別に本物をさっさってやっても
そういう遊びはやめちゃうんですね
そこでこの四つはなんでエシ式と言うんですか？なんでディライブドメターと言うんですか？それは地水火風があるんだからあるんであって
いわゆる地水火風しか何もないんです
その四つが地水火風が組み合わせたところであの働きが生まれちゃうんですね
ただそれだけです ですから
この何か物を持ってきて
我々にはいろんなものを作られるんですね
材料は同じ 一番いい例っていうのは紙なんですね
紙を持ってきたら もう皆様方いろんなことを作るんじゃないんですか？本は作るは
ノートは作るは それだけじゃなくて折り紙という技術の世界まであるんですね
そこで紙をいろんな方法で切ったりして
いろんなものを作ったりするし
箱も作るし 本も作るし
結局材料は紙なんですね
手紙にしたって封筒というものがあるでしょ
あれ ただの紙なんですね
でも紙 1枚と封筒っていうのは全く同じですかね
そうじゃないんですね
紙 1枚では文字は書けるんだけど
他の働きできない でも封筒というのは物を入れて持つことさえできるんですね
それから中にあるものを守ってあげることさえできるんですね
ですから いろんな仕事をできる
仕事をできるんだけど
物は同じなんです ただの 1枚の紙でも折っただけで働きが変わるんですね
紙には何か物を持つことはできませんから
しれません でも それを 4つぐらいに折ったら
中に何か入れることはできるんですね
だから何か特別なことが起こったんで
何も起こってないんです
ちょっと位置が変わっただけなんです
それだけで働きが ファンクションが変わってしまっちゃうんです
仕事が変わってしまっちゃう
あるのは紙だけと その事実を
その現実を見て考えてください
あるのは地水火風だけ
そこで地水火風の 4つのエネルギーをいろんな組み合わせが出てきちゃうと
それなりの働きが違うんですね
同じ水にしても 血の方が
いわゆる血の方というよりは
この まあ火のエネルギーは少なくなったりして
するとそれは氷になっちゃうんですね
氷になるといくらか石に似ているような働きをする
殴られたらもう怪我する
その同じものには もう阿婆の働き
いわゆる墨の働き 風の働きが入ったところで水になってしまったんですね
水になったら水で投げられる
人は私を水を投げちゃっても
私は全然怪我はしません
その代わりに体は濡れるだけ
氷でぶん殴られたら体は濡れませんだけど
怪我はする 水は水なんですけど
働きが変わっちゃうんですね
そこでスチームかけられちゃったら
もう怪我 それでまた怪我するんです
火傷すると でも本質としては水であると
というようなことで 全てのものは本質としては地水火風であるんですが
組み合わせによっていろんな働きはする
その中でも我々には知られるものしか関係はないんです
他のものは 世の中でどんな変化あっても
それは人間は全く知らないであるならば
それは関係ないんです
そういう ちょっと違う例を申し上げます
例えば放射能があるんですね
放射能という現象が 放射能っていうのは見てわからないんですね
見ても全然わからない
じゃあ触ってわかりますかというと
全然わからない じゃあ舐めたところで
これは放射能ありますよと
わかりません 嗅いだところで放射能が入っているものかどうかわかりません
でも我々は放射能にはすごい困ったりする
心配したりする そこで仏教から見れば
放射能なんかはもう馬鹿にすればいいんじゃないかと
と思うかもしれません
でもその場合は馬鹿にすることはできないんですね
放射能は確かに認識できないんです
認識できないんだけど
放射能という物質が 小さい花粉が体に触れちゃうんですね
これ長い間触れて触れていくと
体も小さい花粉の構造が変化する
そこで我々はその変化を認識する
体の変化 その体の変化を認識すると
それは健康には 健康という状態
違う状態だと頭で推測する
だから放射能では困るんだということになってしまっちゃうんですね
でもその場合も 我々には何らかの形で認識することはできるんですね
時間かけて体ががんになったと
白血病になったと 生まれる子供は知恵遅れになったとか
いろいろことで認識できるんです
ですから 認識できないんだから関係ないということは
放射能については言えませんが
全く体に触れることないものは何にも関係ないんです
認識できなくたっても放射能は体に触れるんだから
ですから それは関係あるんです
そこで我々はどうしても我々の体に触れることはないもの
我々にとっては何の関係もない
ということ  そのうちその持って何言ってるか分かるでしょうと思いますけど
うん そこでチャックということは目なんですね
目といったって 私たちには特別に目というものがあるわけじゃなくて
体のある部分で小さい花粉は固まりまして
ありますけど 私たちはものの形を認識するんです
いわゆる外のもの 体 体を求めてものがあるんだと我々は目を通して認識する
その見られる機能 見られる機能にチャックと目と言うんです
この目ん玉でもないんです
目ん玉はただの肉の塊ですけど
でも目ん玉にはある仕事をできるんですね
それは医学的に目のどこら辺とか
それは仏教に関係ないんです
目の 目にはある仕事をできる
鼻にできない仕事 手にできない仕事
それは外の世界があるんだと認識することなんですね
ですから 特別に存在する純粋な幻想があるというよりは
小さい花粉の組み合わせなんですね
この小さい花粉の組み合わせで違う
働きが生まれてきたんです
でも その働きが我々にとってすごい大事なんです
見えるということは 生命には結構あるんですね
見えるという働きが 見えるんだから心が変わるでしょ
いろんなこと考えてるでしょう
我々の善悪の世界やら苦しみの世界やら楽しみの世界やら
すべての世界も いろんなことを我々は見えるということから生まれてくるんですね
いろんなもの ですから
人間にとってはこれ大事なことなんです
だから具体的に目という幻想がありますだとか
こんなくだらない論理するじゃなくて
見えるということは 人間にとってはありとあらゆる幸も不幸も生まれてくる
いろんな知識が生まれてくる大変な問題なんです
ですから 仏教では まあ眼識という物質一つまあ認めちゃうんです
この 二十四 の中で もう 二十八 種類の識の中で眼識という幻想があるんだと
ですから 眼識というものを働きを確定したのはなぜかというと
それは視覚の世界が我々の内なる心にあるんだからね
我々は見たから いろんなものを作ったり
考えたり 悩んだりしているんだから
それはバカにならない
見たんだから生まれる煩悩っていうのは数きれないんですね
見たんだから 我々には捨てることできない執着をいっぱいあるんじゃないんですか
ですから 人間の輪廻転生する原因として見ると
これはバカにならないんです
客観的に見ると 別にそんな大したことないんですね
眼識っていうのは ただの目の中で生まれる直接的働きだけなんです
それは特別な項目に入れちゃって
特別な眼識という物質はあるんだよと確定するほどのものじゃないんだけど
認識の立場から 煩悩の立場から見るとバカにならないもの
だから仏教はそういう角度で物質は区別するんです
物質物理学者の角度じゃないんです
煩悩についての問題なんですね
解脱の問題なんです いわゆる解脱論
煩悩論に基づいて物質論物理学を喋ってるんです
もっと現代風に言えば
認識論に基づいた物質論なんです
認識論ではなくて 認識過程に基づいた物質論になってるんです
だからアビダンマは現代科学にぴったし合う必要
合う必要は全くない これちょっと科学とには合わないんではないかと
だからちょっとまあよしましょうという言葉にはならない
私たちは科学者を追っかけていく必要は全くないんです
我々にとっては一番大事な問題はこういう問題である
科学者が考えている世界は全然問題にならない
例えばニュートリノあるんですよと
まあいろいろ素粒子あるんですが
勝手にあってもいいんですから
別にそれによって私に煩悩生まれたことはないんだから
考えの問題ないんです
じゃあ宇宙の中でどこがどうかで
今新しい新星が発見しました
みんな驚いちゃうんですね
仏教はくだらないことをやるなと
ジャガイモでも植えればいいんじゃないかと
そんな暇があるならば
ということなんです なぜならば
だから新星発見だからどうなるんですか？それだから私たちは新しい苦しみが生まれますか？あるいは新しい幸福が生まれますか？あるいは新しい煩悩が生まれますか
？あるいは持ってる煩悩が消えるんですか？何もないんです
あれはただの暇つぶしなんですね
はっきりと言うと ですから
そういう科学に合うように合うようにと仏教は努力しない
でも一つは 仏教はすごい傲慢というか
もう我が強いところがあるんですね
じゃあ仏教の世界にチャレンジしてみようと
あんた方はいろんな科学的な進歩して発展
発展してきて じゃあ当たってみるとどうなるんですか？と
それがこちらの方が強いってわけなんですね
今私が喋ってるのは これ二千五百年の古い
何の科学もなかった時代でお坊さんたちが開発した心理学なんですね
それもお釈迦様もそこまでやってないんです
なさってないんです お釈迦様さえ
これも面倒くさいな 余計な話だと
お釈迦様はただの仏教だけ喋っていたんですね
それの後のお坊さんたちが
やっぱりアビダンマ論というものは組織化しましたから
物質じゃないんです ですから
物質でもないアビダンマ論にしたっても
科学の世界にはもう何のことなくチャレンジできる
チャレンジするんですよ
それはバカバカらしいことですけどね
いわゆる比べ 肩は並べるというか
もっとちょっと違う立場にいるか
科学者さえ助けてあげることができる立場にいるんですね
科学者でもやっぱり夫婦喧嘩するは
離婚するは がんになったところで悩んだりするは
お金がなくて研究できなくて困ったりするわね
まあそういう精神的なものでいっぱいあるんだから
それを誰が助けてあげるんですか？と
やっぱりこういう世界でしか助けてあげることできませんから
心清らかにすること そういうことでも
まあ我々の立場が違うとということを理解しておいてください
そこでチャックという働きがあります
チャックというのは目ですね
で 目で光は映るんだと
目に光は映るんだというのは物理学者なんです
目で認識できるのは光だよと
この光を映したところで
目の後ろの膜の中であの